who do you think will win the u.s
election oh
wow what a great question uh i warned
you i warned you that we were out of the
safe woods
and we're into this i mean the only
reason i'm hesitant is because i
genuinely don't have a good sense uh
i could tell you who i'd liked to who
i'd like to wait that's not the question
that i asked god
i'm still gonna go with trump will win
would you have said that in april
uh so at the start of the so before
kovid i would have said
it's 95 sure that he would win with
kovid and all of the imbeciles that now
say well look
the deaths it's trump right this is like
your aunt got diabetes during trump well
there's really only one conclusion
it must be that trump caused her
diabetes because bro it's during his
presidency
right an amazonian fraud just died in
the amazon
it is during trump's presidency so how
could you not see the link [ __ ] right
so because most people have the
cognitive abilities of a newborn pigeon
they are regrettably all placing the
blame on trump
so now um i think it's almost a toss-up
i think that the polls
still show biden as winning for similar
reasons as to what happened with hillary
clinton
when it comes down to finally going to
the booths
i still think trump will win if that
happens with the last few months
of very very vehement manipulation by
press
and also such compromise by a lot of the
people who are weaponizing
um movements of goodwill for a political
agenda
on in all different manners by any means
it was a consequentialist
uh outcome that you were talking about
earlier on it's like by any means if we
get him out of office if the orange man
[ __ ] off yeah it's worth it if he gets
voted back in
that is the kitchen sink's been thrown
out the cat's gone at them
you know somewhat someone's pooed in the
hand
they've had a crack a crack at that that
is everything they've thrown at him
and it still hasn't worked yeah uh so
you're saying what would happen if he
were to wait
oh just i just think that if it happens
and he
he does win after every weapon under the
sun that has been picked out by
mainstream media and individuals and
movement groups and stuff like that i
think it's a stark
message about just how wrong
the democrat messaging the left
messaging generally is at the moment and
how much it doesn't resonate with
the normal people not the people that
live on twitter exactly
uh look uh do you want me to talk a bit
about why
a lot of people have a hard time but you
know professor i look up to you how
could you support a maniac like trump
first of all there's a difference
between the positions that i take
and supporting trump right i always say
that i don't have posters of trump which
my wife
and i use in the bedroom as foreplay
right it's so it's
so the fact that i explain why trump is
a very
viable option doesn't mean that i'm a
pro-trump guy i understand that he's
brash and he's vulgar and he's
non-presidential
but as i explained recently in a clip a
sad truth clip
there's an expression that i that that i
bring from from arabic
that basically says to get drunk by
smelling
the cork of the wine bottle right what
is that in arabic please
uh uh means like the raisins but you can
also
apply it for the cork okay so so here's
the here's the cork right
so i could either drink the wine to get
drunk
or i could just go i'm already drunk
now do you understand the the analogy
here that that means that
it takes very little to get me drunk
because i'm a [ __ ] because i'm a
lightweight right
so here's what most people do including
some of my very highfalutin
highbrow cerebral friends okay uh
trump is vulgar he
speaks in a brash way he's cantankerous
he's brazenly boastful
therefore he attacks my sense of
aesthetics this is what i call
an aesthetic injury right but now look
you see
i'm getting drunk you see on the other
hand obama
he's lanky he's tall he's majestic
he's got a radiant smile i'm getting
more drunk by the second you see i'm
getting a bit wobbly right
he's got a millefluous voice oh my god
i'm getting drunk
he's presidential now what obama says
is utter garbage it's rehearsed
platitudinous vacuous [ __ ]
okay if anything the semantics of what
trump might say
might actually be much more substantive
but trump is
vulgar and disgusting he repulses me
therefore he is a monster right this is
why in chapter two
of the parasitic mind i have a section
the chapter is about
feeling versus thinking it is wrong to
pit these two systems against one
another
humans are both a thinking animal and a
feeling animal
the problem is when you activate the
wrong system
at the wrong moment right when i'm
walking down an alley
and i see four young men loitering in
the alley
and my heart starts racing and i start
getting kind of an anxiety thing
so my affective system is kicking in it
makes perfect sense i've evolved
to have that fear response in that case
having my
affective system kick in makes perfect
sense on the other hand if i'm trying to
do well on a
calculus exam my affective system is not
as good to activate as my cognitive
system
so when it comes to choosing my
presidents using my
affective system as the key driver he
disgusts me
he's repulsive he's no he's yes he is
that
but what's the content he supports
freedom of speech
the left doesn't i've already have
enough to support
him the fact that he is a brazen
narcissist i couldn't give a [ __ ]
obama was as much of a narcissist but i
didn't succumb
to the the cork because i see through
his [ __ ]
you get what i'm saying and i think
regrettably most of my
highfalutin colleagues are unable to see
this because
they come from a rarified world where
you
speak i can speak as fancily and
probably ten times more fancy than all
of them combined
but i can also say [ __ ] right and
that
that that's why i say i'm the professor
of the people so i can connect
with trump on his level i get what he's
doing
he's a buffoon in that in a style sense
but the content of what he says he is
against open immigration
he cares more about radical islam so how
could you have one of my friends you
probably can guess who he is
who has historically built his career
criticizing islam
but then when it came to supporting
trump or hillary clinton
he supported hillary clinton who is the
one who would have opened the door
to the whole so how do you reconcile
this well
as he tells me but he disgusts me
[Music]